-I'm gonna make a couple of
calls so I can see you play
with some guys
on your level tomorrow.
-I gotta work.
-How old are you?
-22.
-Basketball years
are like dog years.
If we're gonna do this,
we actually gotta do this now.
-And...how much money
will you pay him?
-To come to Philly?
It'll be
a pro-rated league minimum.
-But you say he was great, for
great, you pay the maximum, no?
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah, yes.
NBA contract
of any kind is maximum, no?
-And how much is the minimum?
-Minimum salary in the NBA
is $900,000.
-He will call in sick.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Adam Sandler.
That was a clip from his new
film, "Hustle," which is great.
-Thank you, man.
-And this is...
this script came via
Lebron James'
production company.
-Yes, yes.
-Him and Maverick Carter,
they're wonderful guys.
-Great guys,
and they have a movie business,
and they had this great script
about a scout
that discovers a guy overseas,
and he tries
to get him in the NBA.
It really was amazing.
So I read the script,
and I was like,
"This is awesome, and thank you
so much for thinking of me."
And I called the guys up,
and I said, "I loved it,
I loved the character,
and I loved the fact that,
you know, he was a scout.
He's smart,
he weighs 220 pounds."
And they were like, "What do
you mean with the 220 pounds?"
And I go, "Well,
it said it in the script
he weighs 250, right?"
And they go,
"You just said 220."
I go, "He weighs 280 pounds..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and I'd love to do it."
And they were like,
"Do you weigh that now?"
I said, "No, I'm 160,
but I can get there in a day."
[ Laughter ]
-Incredible cast, I mean,
you're a natural in it.
Juancho,
who's an actual NBA player,
is a fantastic actor in this.
-Unbelievable. I know.
-Does it drive you crazy when
an athlete's also a good actor?
-All these guys in the movie,
all the NBA guys,
they're just cool.
They're cool, they're confident.
They probably,
their entire life,
have been told they're cool.
They're just better
at everything.
Juancho's just handsome as hell.
He's 6'9", there's
no room he doesn't walk into
that everybody doesn't go,
"Hey, look at that guy."
So, I don't know, he just --
but he was such a great guy,
such a great actor.
And I would tell him
after takes,
'cause he would play it so real
and look deep into my eyes
and say stuff,
and I was going,
"Geez, this guy's good."
But I would tell him
how great he was,
and he'd be like, "At what?"
I'd be like, "At that scene,
you were just great."
He'd go, "oh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
He didn't care. He didn't care.
It meant nothing to him.
-I always thought athletes
were great at "SNL",
because they would never
get nervous
because it was so meaningless
compared to what
they actually did for a living.
-Ah, you're right, you're right.
-Like, no athlete
could be so bad on "SNL"
they'd get cut from a team.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-"I'm one of the best players
in the world, this is stupid."
-Who did you have?
You had Peyton Manning.
-We had Peyton,
we had Brady, yeah.
We had Barkley.
Did you have Barkley?
-We had Barkley, too.
Great, funny guy.
We had Barkley,
we had Michael Jordan.
When I was there,
Michael Jordan hosted.
He hung out with us.
That was, like,
we were so in love with him.
Everyone was in love with MJ
'cause he was such a sweetheart
and so nice to us.
And he would say your name.
Remember when a superstar
says your name,
you're just like,
"He knows my name."
And it's just incredible.
You know what's funny?
I don't know if I ever told you
this -- Bruce Springsteen.
I love Bruce Springsteen,
and so I was working out --
I might've told this story,
but I'll tell it anyways
and you can cut it out
if it's too long.
So I went to a gym on, like,
60th Street in East Side.
I used to work out.
I used to go,
"I'm not as funny
as everybody on the show,
but I'm gonna look better."
[ Laughter ]
Right, so anyways, I work out,
I go to this gym,
and I'm working out
at this real crappy gym.
I forget the name of it.
But anyways,
I keep seeing this guy.
I'm like, "That guy looks like
Bruce Springsteen."
So I go, "Oh, this
can't be Bruce Springsteen."
Anyway, I'm going,
"From that angle,
it looks like Bruce Springsteen.
We're working out
at the same gym.
There're no way he'd be at this
crap gym," blah, blah, blah.
Anyways, I know I'm talking
a lot, but here we go.
So [laughs] anyways,
Bruce Springsteen walks by,
I'm on the thing that --
this one, I'm doing this.
He stops right on me, I'm
looking right at Springsteen.
I'm like, "That is
Bruce Springsteen."
He goes, "Hey." I go, "Hey."
And he goes, "I know you,"
and I go, "You do?"
And he goes,
"You're, uh, Allan Stanley."
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
So, anyways, I come back
to the show,
and I see Farley,
I'm like, "Dude,
I saw Bruce Springsteen
at the gym."
He's like, "No you didn't."
I go, "He knew me! He knew me!"
And he's like, "There no way
that's -- there's no way."
I go, "He called me Allan
Stanley, but he knew me,
he recognized me from the show,"
and blah, blah, blah.
So anyways, and then everyone's
kind of, the next day,
walking around, they're going,
they're saying, like,
"You're lying."
And I was like,
"It was Bruce Springsteen,
he knew me,"
and blah, blah, blah.
So, like, two years later,
Springsteen is the musical guest
on the show,
and he's coming by
and he's saying hi to everybody
and blah, blah, blah.
And I'm standing there, I'm
like, "There's no way," right?
Then he looks at me
and goes, "Hey, man,"
and everyone
kind of looks and he goes,
"You still go to that gym?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "That's right."
-Allan Stanley!
-Allan Stanley.
-Keeping it tight.
-Yeah.
-Hey, congratulations
on the film. It's fantastic.
It is always the best
to have you here.
You guys, Adam Sandler.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hustle" in select theaters now
and available on Netflix
tomorrow.
We'll be right back
with James Patterson.